la mejor manera de hablar sobre el
proceso de digestión y el duodeno es
hablar sobre las cuatro macromoléculas
principales que fabrican todo en nuestro
cuerpo comenzando con las proteínas las
proteínas son simplemente cadenas de
aminoácidos de modo que hay un
aminoácido aquí y hay otro aminoácido
acá y están conectados por algo que se
llama enlace peptídicos después de las
proteínas también tenemos carbohidratos
los carbohidratos son unidades repetidas
de azúcares simples unidas entre sí
puedes nombrar un azúcar simple claro
creo que dijiste glucosa algo como
glucosa unida digamos a galactosa sería
un disacárido este disacárido en
particular se llama lactosa así que un
solo azúcar se considera un monosacárido
dos de ellos un disacárido y muchos de
ellos serían un polisacárido además de
los carbohidratos también tenemos
nucleótidos estos forman nuestro ácido
nucleico nuestro adn y están compuestos
de tres partes principales
hay un grupo fosfato que está unido a un
azúcar ribosa que estoy dibujando aquí
este pequeño pentágono y justo aquí está
unida a una base esta base es el
recubrimiento de tu adn como la adenina
o la guanina si has escuchado esos
nombres antes
finalmente también tenemos lípidos los
lípidos tienen dos partes una cabeza de
triglicéridos que tiene estos tres
grupos de oxígeno y luego cada uno de
estos oxígenos tiene una cola de ácido
graso hay 1 2 3 de modo que tenemos 3
colas de ácidos grasos aquí ahora que
sabemos cuáles son las macromoléculas
más importantes podemos hablar sobre los
procesos principales que están
involucrados en romperlas para que
puedan ser absorbidas por nuestro
torrente sanguíneo comenzando con
nuestras proteínas hay enzimas que están
presentes en el borde en cepillo para
ayudar a romper nuestros enlaces
peptídicos o enlaces de aminoácidos así
que solo escribiré péptidos
porque como recordarás cada vez que
nombras una enzima que termine en asa
significa que lo que está antes es lo
que está roto entonces un enlace
peptídicos se rompe por una perdida
además el páncreas trae consigo un par
de enzimas importantes que ayudarán a
romper las proteínas en primer lugar
tiene trips y no gen o así como algo de
kim o trips y no gen o cada vez que
encuentras geno al final del nombre de
una enzima significa que no está lista
para trabajar significa que todavía
necesita un corte o incisión más antes
de que pueda comenzar a ser
completamente funcional
bueno aquí es donde nuestro borde en
cepillo vuelve a ser útil porque hay una
enzima presente en el borde en cepillo
que se llama entero peptidasa y que está
específicamente presente para
descomponer el trips y no gen o en su
forma activa que se llama tripsina y lo
mismo sucede con el quimo tryp sino que
no se descompone en quimo tripsina
estos también serán capaces de
descomponer el enlace peptídicos como lo
hacen las peptidasas pero necesitan un
pequeño corte para empezar a trabajar y
una vez que engullimos nuestras
proteínas tendremos subunidades de
aminoácidos simples que serán absorbidas
cuando llegamos a los carbohidratos nos
damos cuenta de que el páncreas es muy
útil aquí también porque libera una
enzima que se llama amilasa que puede
ayudar a romper el enlace de azúcar o
este enlace glucose hídrico que es otro
nombre que se le da en ciertos
carbohidratos el borde en cepillo
también es útil aquí porque tiene muchas
enzimas específicas que rompen el enlace
glucose y dico entre azúcares simples
muy específicos por ejemplo la enzima en
el borde en cepillo que se conoce como
lactasa sólo se puede usar para
descomponer la lactosa como lo he
dibujado aquí ahora lo interesante de la
lactosa que debo mencionar es que cuando
tienes gastroenteritis y tienes un [ __ ]
en tu barriga se puede comenzar a
inflamar la pared del duodeno y al
hacerlo puede
algunas de las enzimas de lactasa del
borde en cepillo así no tendrás lactasa
y no podrás descomponer la lactosa no
podrá separar la glucosa de la galactosa
de modo que temporalmente vas a ser
intolerante a la lactosa la mayoría de
las personas recuperan esta habilidad
pero ahora puedes entender lo valiosas
que son para nosotros estas enzimas del
borde en cepillo ayudarán a romper
ciertos y zachary 2 el páncreas también
hará su trabajo y finalmente tendrás
azúcares simples que se van a quedar por
ahí y recuerda el nombre de cada unidad
se llama monosacárido cuando se trata de
los nucleótidos el borde en cepillo
también ayuda el conjunto de enzimas
específicas que tenemos en el borde en
cepillo que ayuda a separar los
nucleótidos se llaman núcleos y danzas y
la razón por la que tenemos núcleos y
danzas y no nucleótidos es porque se
rompe este vínculo lo que resulta en un
grupo fosfato unido a un azúcar ribosa
ahora tenemos nuestra base como una
unidad completamente separada del
nucleótido finalmente cuando se trata de
lípidos vamos a tener algo de ayuda de
la bilis como mencioné anteriormente la
bilis si recuerdas proviene de nuestro
hígado y nuestra vesícula biliar de modo
que van a liberar algo de bilis en
nuestro duodeno ayudarán a emulsionar u
organizar los lípidos así que escribiré
aquí entre paréntesis organizar porque
no están realmente involucrados en
descomponer los están ahí para ayudar a
organizarlos una de las principales
cosas que nos ayudan a descomponer los
es el páncreas el páncreas libera algo
que se llama lipasa la lipasa entra y
corta justo aquí de esa manera cada una
de estas cadenas individuales de ácidos
grasos se rompe y así tendrás estas tres
cadenas de ácidos grasos que están
colgando aquí incluyendo la cabeza de
triglicéridos todo esto va a ser una
unidad separada ahora tienes estas
cuatro cosas que salieron de esta
molécula de lípidos